oltre ad essere un insegnante nella
pratica la meditazione sono
un'insegnante di storia e sono
soprattutto un essere umano e in quanto
tale nutro l'abitudine periodicamente
regolarmente di
ricontestualizzarmi mi pongo domande del
tipo dove sono o forse da storico
soprattutto quando sono in quale epoca
storica In quale è congiuntura In quale
momento ora
da una ventina di anni in qua vi è
sempre un consenso Maggiore Tra gli
studiosi nel definire quest'epoca come
antropocene l'età dell'essere umano
Quella fase storica in cui siamo in
grado di trasformare di modificare tutto
dai codici genetici alla vita alla
biodiversità ai sistemi
ecologici e Oserei dire Addirittura il
clima nel quale Viviamo e siamo anche
molto bravi nel ignorare le conseguenze
qualche volta gravi Talora addirittura
catastrofiche o drammatiche delle nostre
azioni in tal senso quest'epoca può
essere anche definita come
agnotocene l'età dell'ignoranza
ignoranza vista un po' come paura paura
di conoscere paura di sapere paura della
consapevolezza ho paura delle scomode
verità Come direbbe algor E questo ci
porta a una terza possibile definizione
per questo periodo che è quella di
phobocene l'età della paura l'età delle
paure abbiamo paura della proliferazione
del conflitto in Ucraina la paura di una
testata nucleare in testa la paura della
crisi economica la paura di perdere il
posto di lavoro di non arrivare alla
fine del mese la paura delle bollette
della luce e del gas ma anche la paura
dello straniero del diverso del migrante
e non da ultimo la paura del cambiamento
climatico dei possibili estremi
climatici che ci colpiscono
imprevedibilmente la paura della grande
incertezza ora nella tradizione che
rappresento la paura può essere vista
sia come qualche cosa di individuale di
soggettivo Oserei dire quasi di intimo
Ma la paura è anche vista come un
fenomeno collettivo la paura è
contagiosa forse più del covid
in questa tradizione che si rifà come è
stato detto alla Buddismo in modo
particolare al buddismo tibetano si
parla di tradizione Shambala la paura
riveste un ruolo estremamente importante
Magari apro una piccola parentesi ma
tendenzialmente
la il buddismo che è considerato una
delle grandi religioni mondiali vede
comunque nel Buddha un personaggio un
po' particolare non è un Dio non è un
creatore non è un Salvatore è
semplicemente un essere umano che ha
effettuato nel corso della vita
attraverso un certo percorso una
scoperta di cui parlerò tra breve e
quindi buddisti spesso preferiscono
parlare di filosofia di psicologia in
quanto l'oggetto del buddismo l'oggetto
di studio e soprattutto la mente umana o
addirittura di scienza
In ogni caso in questa tradizione la
paura viene definita come qualsiasi
strategia noi mettiamo in atto per
evitare la nostra saggezza innata la
nostra intelligenza primordiale o per
usare un termine un po' provocatorio la
nostra bontà fondamentale questa parola
traduce il tibetano Domine sangpo che
letteralmente significa
completezza incondizionata siamo
naturalmente dotati di tutte le qualità
di tutte le virtù possibili e
immaginabili
ma non ci fidiamo più di tanto di questo
fatto vi spiego meglio In che cosa
consiste questo stato Perché
sostanzialmente si tratta di
un'esperienza di uno stato mentale viene
talvolta descritto attraverso tre
qualità o tre categorie e la prima è
quella della vastità o dell'apertura
immaginatevi per un momento in una bella
giornata di primavera o autunnale di
sdraiarvi nel bel mezzo di un prato
pancia all'insù a osservare il cielo ma
non ad osservarlo distrattamente a
cercare di identificarne il fondo
sondandone la profondità
questa esperienza visto che la nostra
mente tende a identificarsi con i suoi
oggetti viene tecnicamente definita come
Mescolare la mente con lo spazio la
mente diventa spaziosa stereofonica e
aperta
ora quando la mente si trova in questo
stato automaticamente diviene Pure
questa è la seconda qualità più
sensibile più percettiva più attenta
alle diverse sfaccettature della realtà
si parla in questo caso di brillantezza
o di luminosità
e quando la mente è aperta e sensibile
esprime automaticamente
spontaneamente
empatia calore umano
compassione disponibilità a mettersi nei
panni degli altri e quindi ad aiutare
secondo la situazione davanti alla quale
ci troviamo
Quindi dentro di noi è un po' come se ci
fosse un enorme potenziale di apertura
di sensibilità e di compassione ma è un
po' come se questo stesso potenziale ci
sembrasse troppo e quindi quando vediamo
questo sole brillante nel bel mezzo di
un cielo blu tendiamo a coprire a
indossare magari degli occhiali da sole
o cospargerci il corpo di una crema ad
altissima protezione
sono queste strategie che vengono
definite in questa tradizione come paura
in tutto il ventaglio possibile
immaginabile delle nostre paure a
cominciare dalla paura con la p
maiuscola che è la paura della morte non
saremo qui in eterno la nostra vita
verrà meno Poi ci sono le piccole paure
psicologiche dettate dalle delusioni
dalle umiliazioni dai feedback negativi
Oppure ancora l'ansia da prestazione la
paura di non essere all'altezza vi posso
garantire che questa paura L'ho vissuta
e sperimentata piuttosto regolarmente da
questa primavera quando mi è stato fatto
l'invito a questo evento giuro
poi abbiamo altre paure l'aggressività
espressione di paura reazione di difesa
l'attaccamento o l'avidità possono
essere viste come paura di rimanere soli
o paura di rimanere senza
la noia può essere vista come paura di
non avere feedback di ritorno positivi o
negativi che siano e forse da ultimo
possiamo immaginare la paura lo stato
puro chiamata panico
ora questa paura tende a proliferare e
nella tradizione shamballah esiste una
metafora ampiamente conosciuta che si
riferisce all'idea del Bozzolo In altri
termini la paura ci porta ad
imbozzolarci in una serie di schemi
abituali che ci fanno sentire al sicuro
Forse a questa è il bello della metafora
del Bozzolo Il baco da seta dentro il
Bozzolo si sente al sicuro ma se lo
osserviamo da fuori potremmo capire
Forse non è proprio in una botte di
ferro in un bunker atomico
con i suoi rischi e nello stesso tempo
dentro questo bossolo Ci sentiamo al
sicuro Trump c'è che ha portato questi
insegnamenti in Occidente diceva che
quando siamo dentro il Bozzolo ci
posizioniamo in posizione fetale
rannicchiati E assaporiamo l'odore
familiare delle nostre ascelle perché ci
rassicura
Quindi qual è il problema in questo caso
della paura È la sua costante e continua
replicazione la paura prolifera la paura
in ultima analisi ci fa soffrire e forse
il problema sta qui nessuno di noi ama
soffrire
ora in questo paradigma entra in gioco
la pratica della meditazione la pratica
della meditazione è una pratica di
consapevolezza di puro riconoscimento
non vogliamo migliorarci semplicemente
vogliamo osservare vedere e questa
osservazione è estremamente potente
quando vogliamo vedere come siamo fatti
Fisicamente ci rispecchiamo al bagno in
camera nostra in uno specchio fisico
quando vogliamo vedere come siamo fatti
mentalmente psicologicamente ci
riscopriamo ci rispecchiamo nello
specchio della meditazione
e che avviene una trasformazione
estremamente potente la paura
si trasforma in paura
bella cosa direte voi forse la cosa va
un attimino chiarita potremmo dire che i
nostri meccanismi abituali che ci
portano ad evitare la paura quindi la
paura della paura la paura della paura
della paura si trasforma in semplice
paura paura allo stato puro paura nuda e
cruda e questo è ciò che ci rende umani
perché in quanto esseri umani siamo
sostanzialmente
fragili vulnerabili possiamo fingere
possiamo pretendere di non esserlo ma lo
siamo e quindi la pratica la meditazione
ci riporta a questa semplice verità la
paura completamente vissuta ci porta ad
essere umani e possiamo avere fiducia in
questo fatto a questo punto la cosa
diventa potente
la paura in sé non è un problema se ci
pensiamo bene
il fatto di essere qui è dovuto al fatto
di avere paura non solo perché siamo qui
perché siamo interessati al tema ma
semplicemente perché senza paura non
saremmo sopravvissuti fino a questo
punto
la paura è attenzione e circospezione è
prudenza è intelligenza
nella
tradizione Shambala la praticante o il
praticante sono definiti come guerriera
o guerriero non nel senso di
guerrafondai semplicemente coloro che
hanno il coraggio di stare con la
propria paura di toccare la propria
paura di accarezzarla di abbracciarla di
sorridere alla paura